o cérebro tem se aproximadamente 100
bilhões de neurônios isso são 15 vezes
mais que a população mundial e tem
contra o leão das sinapses ligações como
estradas dentro desse pequeno universo
que temos dentro descreve o problema
imagine a tentar encontrar o caminho
dentro do sistema é extremamente
complexo certo mas no mundo temos hoje
em dia ferramentas do novo telemóvel
como o google maps que nos indica o
caminho muito facilmente de um ponto a
outro no porto como chegar até roma
certo
todos os caminhos levam a roma mas como
encontrar e esse caminho não é muito
fácil e essa tecnologia seis mapas até
nos indicam a situação do trânsito ou se
a acidentes pelo caminho
agora imaginem ter essa tecnologia ter
este mapa oferece um google mapas para o
cérebro seria muito útil certo mas o
problema é com o cérebro é extremamente
complexo incrivelmente complexo imagine
um universo uma escala aqui fechado
o problema tem sido esse é extremamente
complexo e para isso tem estado dentro
de um crânio que nos tempos livres vir
do olhar dentro e criar um mapa
realmente estudar e e criar as teorias
para entender os 10
isso também temos inclusive entender o
de detectar se há alguma esse problema
zona das doenças os transtornos mentais
são ainda hoje em dia contando até com
11 mas ainda são detectadas o
diagnóstico é feito quando os primeiros
sintomas surgem com perguntas subjetivas
como é este exercício normal é normal
afinal como é que dormiram como é que
dormir ao paciente o mês passado
perguntas muito subjetivas ou cento
frisou infeliz
são coisas muito negativas portanto
necessitamos de uma forma mais objetiva
mais qualificada
tentar determinar se essas doenças estão
dentro de um cérebro não por todos
vivemos mais tempo
a população está a envelhecer e os
estudos científicos dizem até com um
terço da população irá sofrer em algum
momento de uma doença do cérebro como
alzheimer o parkinson esclerose múltipla
e certamente os conhecemos alguém
infelizmente nas nossas famílias o os
nossos amigos com uma dessas doenças
o problema tem sido isso não temos tido
as ferramentas para vir para olhar
dentro do cérebro
mas nem tudo são más notícias vivemos
uma época fantástica com tecnologia
incrível como clara tem que nos dá
imagens como a claridade impressionante
com com um talhão pornô espetacular até
dos neurônios e os pontos verdes mais
variantes às ligações
estas linhas estão uma pequena parte de
um córtex de um animal de um de um caso
neste caso em campo - claro que ainda é
necessário e dentro do crânio é
necessário sacrificar o sujeito o animal
neste caso não dá muito jeito em termos
de diagnóstico mas todos conhecemos a
questionar-se magnética esta máquina
esta é a marca incrível é como uma
câmera fotográfica que tira centenas e
centenas de fotos dentro do interior do
corpo mas essa informação não tem sido
muito aproveitado para o cérebro que é
extremamente complexo
como tinha dito essas imagens são
confirmadas vindas de diferentes cortes
do entre 10 vemos os detalhes principais
o crânio da matéria cinzenta por fora
assim com um cinzento escuro por dentro
temos a matéria branca mas tudo parece
ter a mesma cor mas o certo é
extremamente complexo como dizia é um
tem uma rede de ligações onde andava há
uma série de estrutura mostrou se
extremamente complexa dentro dessas
imagens
infelizmente também a amatec um erro
tremendo nova cerca de 20 anos em que
surgiu o chamado na cidade de difusão em
princípio muito simples o nosso corpo
está cheio de água
o sérvio está cheio de água e se
pensarmos no interior do cérebro com os
ventrículos comum
op é uma parte do zero um pequeno corpo
um pequeno buraco
chegamos com um líquido em eventos como
se fosse um copo de água
as marcas de água móveis livro - dentro
desta vez trata-se da então nova lei
eleitoral mente e está livre os
movimentos da matéria branca causa da
fibras como se fossem palhinha são
pequenos tubos
isso é quase água móveis mais ao longo
das bolinhas e batendo nas paredes
então essa idéia é muito simples muito
grande diz almir água
temos em todo o corpo podemos então ter
em cada ponto
a estrutura em que direção está
estruturando nesse mesmo ano do zero
isto a principalmente a tecnologia que
usamos porque a partir de então de
imagens a preto e branco centenas de
imagens a preto e branco
as ferramentas computacionais que muitos
tentam passar imagens a cores cor indica
a direcção da estrutura do tecido meus
pontos
imagens em 2d record se passarmos a
imagem em 3d
temos aqui por exemplo 10 penso que seja
o mesmo do lado esquerdo é o inferno
esquerdo lado direito inferior direito e
esta estrutura vermelha no centro do
corpo caloso que integra a informação do
nosso lado criativo ao lado matemática o
lado metódico essa estrutura grandes e
vermelha dentro do número da imagem
e esta quantidade não era da informação
e imagens
há uma diferença que gosta e todos
ocorreram do projeto genoma humano dez
anos com o objetivo de mapear
completamente o rn certo o nosso genoma
e quantidade de novas tecnologias e
desenvolvimento da medicina
personalizada novos tratamentos novos
medicamentos com quantidade indústria e
e ao poder torno neste instrumento como
esse projeto enorme da humanidade pois
agora estamos na época do conectoma e
mapear as conexões do cérebro existem
várias iniciativas nos estados unidos na
europa e no japão em vários pontos do
globo como objetivo obter mais e mais de
dados no vídeo serve para mapear o
cérebro
isso tudo para que afinal pra que eles
eram essas imagens todas
o meu grupo a minha equipe em barcelona
alguns exemplos de casos em que estamos
a trabalhar por exemplo como o hospital
são joão de deus no hospital infantil
estamos a trabalhar com um sintoma de
uma doença que há uma mutação de um gene
nas crianças e isso cria que haja
sintomas como epilepsia semelhantes à
epilepsia ou semelhantes a para que o
seu organismo
imagine uma doença que geralmente está
associada à a a invernos mais mais
avançadas ou problemas visuais problemas
de expressão
isto cria e nos problema em tentar
determinar um diagnóstico preciso para
ter um tratamento adequado
mas com as novas ferramentas e essas
ferramentas computacionais no dia e como
está o cérebro dentro
podemos medir qual é o desenvolvimento
normal do cérebro e poder então comparar
quais são as diferenças que partes do
cérebro são distintas na como como os
doentes com essas crianças e um gráfico
muitos nome científico mas além azul
simplesmente é o crescimento normal do
cérebro da matéria cinzenta a um
crescimento rápido até cerca de dois
anos e depois branda mas claramente
vemos que os pacientes é vermelha
isso não se passa uma alma um
crescimento mais lento ou até uma
geração dessa parte então essas
ferramentas ao poder com essas imagens
coloridas podemos identificar
precisamente onde está o problema
cena parte visual na parte cognitiva e
ajudar que estamos a fazer é ajudar os
neuro pediatra a ter o tratamento
personalizado para essa criança seja
como estimulação magnética ou com música
com 90 - e outro grande foco da minha
equipa em barcelona é esclerose múltipla
esclerose com uma doença alusões
aleatórias no cérebro como se fossem
pequenos buracos dentro das duas faltas
nos falta da do do cérebro e isso cria
problemas de transporte de informação
nesse transporte informação mas agora
com as ferramentas como posso podem ver
aqui neste vídeo temos 10 com suas
transparente com as linhas as estradas
de comunicação bem representadas
identificadas e que os cubanos é uma das
razões dentro do cérebro do paciente e o
neurologista tem literalmente nas suas
mãos o cérebro do paciente um gps e pode
identificar onde está o problema onde
está usando que cria sua gestão
danificadas e poder então para dizer e
até mais poder realmente vir senão o
tratamento está a ser efectiva ou não
esse é o grande problema e como estou
com essas imagens todas com isso dados
todos ouvir um cérebro mapear o cérebro
estamos a construir um museu e um
cérebro saudável da mesma forma que
agora é totalmente normal e demolir ter
uma análise do sangue e temos nosso
valor do los hermanos está normal ou não
imagine ter essa informação para o
cérebro a queda ano a partir de uma
certa idade ter uma ressonância
magnética e poder comparar está normal o
naoum começa a surgir ao que é um cavalo
ligeiramente distinto com essa
informação
imagine num futuro muito próximo em 45
anos ter as ferramentas para a deteção
precoce dessas doenças
por quanto mais anos mais avançado antes
dos sintomas surgirem se podemos ir um
dois três anos seja uma semana mais cedo
os sintomas têm uma oportunidade para os
novos tratamentos poderem atrasar ou até
parar o ocorrer o desenvolvimento da
doença e então realmente ter a
possibilidade de ter um impacto brutal
na vida dos pacientes e das suas
famílias